>> Greg: SINCE COVID NO LONGER
SHOCKS, BRING IN THE MONKEYPOX.
YEAH, THEY ARE TRYING TO PREPARE
US FOR A NEW DISEASE TO SCARE
US, CHIN FISH ADVICE FROM THE
CDC, WEAR A MASK AND STAY OUT OF
TREES.
SO, THE CDC RAISED THE MONKEYPOX
ALERT TO LEVEL 2 YESTERDAY COME
UPGRADING FROM MARMOT SET TO
BABOON.
REPRIMANDING TRAVELERS WEAR
MASKS TO AVOID CATCHING IT, BUT
THEN THEY LATER REMOVED THE
MASKED RECOMMENDATION, PROBABLY
AFTER THEY REALIZED IT IS
PRIMARILY SPREAD THROUGH SKIN TO
SKIN CONTACT.
THAT IS PUTTING IT POLITELY.
THERE ARE THREE TOTAL ADVISORY
LEVELS.
ONE BEING THE LOWEST AND THREE
THE HIGHEST.
THEY USE THIS SYSTEM BECAUSE
BIDEN CAN NO LONGER COUNT TO
FOUR.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW, THIS PANIC IS BEING SERVED
UP DESPITE THE FACT MOST CASES
HAVE BEEN LINKED TO RANDOM
EUROPEAN RAVES, WHERE THE
PARTICIPANT'S LACK OF MASKS WAS
NOT THE HIGHEST RISK BEHAVIOR.
FYI, THE LEATHER MASK THEY GAVE
OUT WERE COMPLETELY USELESS.
BUT I AM STILL WEARING MINE
AROUND THE HOUSE WHEN I AM
DUSTING MY FIGURINES.
[LAUGHTER]
IN ANY CASE -- IN ANY CASE, NO
ONE IS MORE EXCITED ABOUT ALL OF
THIS THAN ANTHONY FAUCI, WHO
SPENT THE WEEKEND IRONING ALL OF
HIS SHIRTS SO THEY ASK AND BACK.
WHAT WILL HE BE WRONG ABOUT THIS
TIME?
CHINA EATING MONKEYS?
WHO KNOWS.
MEANWHILE THE CDC'S NEWEST HEAD
DOCTOR HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE
TO CLEAR UP ANY CONFUSION.
[LAUGHTER]
[MONKEY NOISES]
>> DOCTOR, DOCTOR, KEN
VACCINATED PEOPLE HAVE BE 27
WITH MONKEYS?
CAN'T YOU JUST WEAR MASKS WHILE
HAVING SEX WITH A MONKEY?
[MONKEY NOISES]
DOCTOR, WHAT IF I GIVE YOU A
BANANA FIRST?
THEN CAN WE HAVE SEX?
[MONKEY NOISES]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THAT MIGHT BE THE
BEST THING WE HAVE EVER DONE.
[LAUGHTER]
IT IS SO HARD TO GET SCARED OF
SOMETHING THAT SOUNDS SO
ADORABLE.
>> I DISAGREE.
ON THE ONE HAND, I AM NOT THAT
WORRIED ABOUT IT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT IS A POX,
AND THAT IS LIKE, EW.
I AM NOT A SCIENTIST BUT I DID
SPEND LIKE THREE HOURS READING
ABOUT IT, AND I DON'T WANT IT.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: YEAH, THERE ARE A LOT
OF POXES OUT THERE.
>> A POX, AND YOU HAVE TO STAY
HOME FOR THREE WEEKS BECAUSE
YOUR FACE IS COVERED IN POX.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK IT IS
ON YOUR FACE.
>> WELL...
>> Greg: FROM THE PICTURES I
SAW.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT I TOOK.
>> THERE ARE CONFLICTING REPORTS
AND I JUST FEEL LIKE STATISTICS
DON'T MEAN MUCH TO ME WHEN IT
COMES TO MEDICAL ABNORMALITIES.
I WILL PROBABLY GET THE
MONKEYPOX.
>> PROBABLY WILL --
>> PROBABLY.
THE ONE OUTLIER.
HOW DID SHE GET THE POX?
WE DON'T KNOW BUT SHE GOT A REAL
BAD.
>> LOOK BEHIND YOU.
>> Greg: ISN'T IT FUNNY HOW
THE CDC COULD NOT SAY HOW TO
SPREAD IT BECAUSE I WOULD BE
POLITICALLY INCORRECT?
>> YOU ARE READING MY MIND.
ONCE YOU MAKE MEDICINE
POLITICAL, YOU CAN NO LONGER
GIVE A MESSAGE.
THIS WHOLE THING WHERE DOCTORS
HAVE TO BE SOOTHING AND KIND AND
RESPECT EVERYONE'S WISHES AND
PRONOUNS -- YOU ARE A DOCTOR OF
SCIENCE.
SAY IT.
HOW DO YOU GET IT?
WHO NEEDS TO BE MOST CONCERNED
WITH IT?
AND IT IS UNCOMFORTABLE, AND I
AM SORRY, AND IF YOU GET IT, NO
ONE AROUND YOU ISN'T GOING TO
KNOW HOW YOU GOT IT.
YOU KNOW?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: PAB, WELCOME BACK TO
THE SHOW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MONKEYPOX.
I THINK IT IS SPREAD THROUGH
ANAL SEX WITH STRANGERS YOU MEET
AT A MUSIC FESTIVAL.
CHARACTER, AND?
[LAUGHTER]
>> LOOKING AT ME.
THE CDC, WHY DID THEY RECOMMEND
MASKS IN THE FIRST PLACE?
THEY KNOW IT IS NOT AIRBORNE.
IN CLOSE, INTIMATE CONTACT THERE
COULD BE RESPIRATORY SPREAD, BUT
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT INTIMATE
CONTACT, SO IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THEY WERE SPREADING A PANIC BY
EVEN TELLING PEOPLE AND THEY DID
IT WITH THE WHOLE COVID, SAYING
LESS THAN 10% OF COVID CASES ARE
TRANSMITTED OUTDOORS, IT TURNED
OUT THE ACTUAL NUMBER WAS .001%.
TECHNICALLY IT WAS ACCURATE, BUT
IT IS INTELLECTUALLY DISHONEST.
>> Greg: I DON'T LIKE ANYONE
EVER DIED FROM OUTDOOR EXPOSURE
TO COVID.
THAT JUST TOTALLY -- WE COULD
HAVE DONE SO MUCH OUTDOOR STUFF
AT RAVES.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW HOW MANY RAVES I MISSED
BECAUSE OF THE WHOLE COVID
THING?
THE ORANGUTANS IN LONDON.
WE WERE JUST GOING TO A PARTY.
>> LOOK, I'M GOING TO REWRITE
THE CDC MEMO FOR EVERYONE'S
BENEFIT.
STEP ONE: DON'T [BLEEP] A
MONKEY.
[APPLAUSE]
ARE YOU WRITING THIS DOWN?
THIS IS GOLD, WRITE THIS DOWN.
>> Greg: STEP TWO OUT: DON'T
HAVE RANDOM
SEX AT EUROPEAN RAVES.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT U.S. RAVES.
OR LATIN RAVES.
BUT I'M PRETTY SURE ABOUT THE
EUROPEAN ONES.
AND I WOULD CLOSE OFF THE MEMO
BY SAYING, SINCERELY, MIK